When I was young, games were developed only by big companies
Which includes hundreds of employees and generates millions of dollars.
Now any two friends can meet at leisure and develop games.
The Balloons was one of the first great games we developed,
It is a classic balloons game.
It was the first thing everyone said
It is difficult and impossible, not fun for users.
Although we had an audience,
But not asking for comments hurt us a lot.
This is what we did in "KleptoCats".
We did nothing at all and then we checked all the comments
Sent by users to try to improve the game.
We discover the sensitive point between what we offer
And what users want to be able to continue.
To encourage players to continue playing,
We try to improve the sources of fun and the aspects that make the games interesting.
We believe it at times
When you make a surprise gift for you, the game offers a lot of emotions.
It is a kind of gifts offered by Gasha machines,
Where you get a gift you do not know what.
For a long time, the simplified games were not desirable, but this is not our opinion.
We have adopted the development of simplified games and try to provide experiences that respect your time
It does not include a barrier to entry.
The mission of SkyAlert is to save lives.
Mexico is constantly exposed to earthquakes.
So we need to invent technology that will help us live better,
And to coexist with seismic phenomena,
And better equip our society to deal with them.
What you need to think about when launching a subscription form,
Is the value you will provide to the user.
This app lets you receive multiple notifications in real time
When our network of monitoring devices is confirmed
Of an earthquake.
We started sending warnings about earthquakes, incorporating new features and models.
This will convert users to subscribers,
Achieving a retention rate of approximately 50%.
People continue to use the application daily
Three months after downloading it.
We have about 47% of users paying an annual subscription,
And 53% pay monthly.
Once the application is self-renewing, the company will become self-sustaining.
In the Latin American market, 70% of people are obese.
Only 3% of them can reach the gym.
With InstaFit, users are available without worry,
Or without spending a large amount, or having to go to a gym,
Or purchase equipment or weights,
Where they receive daily programs
Very diverse and includes all kinds of exercises,
It can be done at home
In an area of ​​10 square feet without needing anything else.
The subscription form is the future.
The subscription form lets you plan your earnings
Thus creating a sustainable business that grows through the user base involved.
Last year, we achieved a growth of 450% in the Android subscriber base,
Because of hiring a better team of internal developers.
We devoted much more resources to the marketing budget,
We started to do a lot of optimization tests
In both the acquisition and retention of users exclusively on Android.
One of our tests included a change
The trial period is 7 days to 30 days.
This had a direct effect that led to a 25%
In the size of free trial periods.
Understand the needs of users
And support them during the application usage experience
You can establish a business that grows through a loyal user base
Who have been following your app for a long time.